hello friends I'm Ilana and welcome to
my channel today I'm doing something a
little bit different
basically I've made some content
recently that is not family-friendly and
we all know YouTube doesn't like that so
when playful Studios reached out to me
and asked if I would play a new Super
Lucky's tale on my channel I was frankly
pretty excited about the opportunity to
do something kid-friendly but I would
never just be kind to myself and sit
down and play a game on my switch
without hating myself a little bit a
while ago I asked people to help me fill
out this wheel for when I am playing
switch games I'm gonna spin this thing
when I finish a level a new super
Lucky's tale and give myself a
punishment to make the next level hotter
I loved it the one hand ones the the
ones that are covered by my screen
screen there you go got it
there you go lost film in one hand if it
gets on the yellow ones which big X's I
get a free round but to explain what's
on here I did have my chat choose these
so this would be my first time actually
using it we have roast after roast to
myself while playing through a level one
hand is controlling both joy constant
one and that one's gonna be tough
blindfolded potentially impossible swap
joke on I have to swap the hands at the
joy cleanser and I feel like that's
gonna be really disorientating while
flailing I just have to move the whole
time last film I have to describe the
plot of the last film that I saw or the
one before that or the one before that
depending on how many times I spin that
one without actually naming it vinegar
take a shot of vinegar accent only I
have to do the whole thing while
speaking in a different accent but first
off because I haven't actually played
this game why don't I would just not
spin to begin with hey cutie okay so we
just got some backstory is I guess it's
gonna be a tutorial area I can't
don't fall good there is no way I'm
doing this blindfolded
he is very cute is this how people get
into furries
combat this is definitely on people get
into furry dungeon run all right Oh cuz
it's gonna be a side-scroller
there's a lot they could make this hard
oh it's on a timer oh but I haven't spun
yet oh oh he runs oh no I have to spin
okay okay we got roast I have to roast
myself the whole time great love it okay
um oh you talk about how you have an
illness but all it really does to you is
make you sleepy when other people have
actual illnesses that require doing
things you look like a horse combined
with a homeless person who moonlights as
an actress but only in btf films because
nobody else would ever want to see your
face in high definition you despite the
fact that you like think you're all
feminine and you you have your long hair
and stuff you still dress like a dude
and you have a real deep voice so you
know doing your best but you're not
fooling anybody definitely still a
tomboy Ilana I don't like this at all
you did this to yourself you making this
a wholesome content and even this you
couldn't do without adding self-loathing
terms into it you can't make a single
happy thing without hating it excellent
let it be done at least he's happy for
me I appreciate it lucky you little
cutie bummer I missed the yell I didn't
do a great job
no the roast is Donilon he can be nice
to yourself now Sarah I can see that
platform with this oh there are tons of
oh you're not even in a level oh I mean
yes I meant to do that
that was intentional okay we need to do
another spin another puzzle what is it
accent only oh well this one's easy I
just have to do next scent the whole
time and when the chat suggested this
one I was like you know what that's
actually the best I can do plenty of
them I guess I just chose to do this one
oh this actually does look a little bit
harder though doesn't it oh I have to
get the little foxes specifically on to
their marks here no I think I already
know how to do this we just have to the
accents definitely inconsistent there
isn't it we have to just mMmmm to see I
am actually failing this is harder for
me to think about and play at the same
time than I would have expected I
screwed it up how can I get him back
there okay no no here's what we did we
just do this and it's hard to keep track
of what I'm saying oh my god get me out
of this leave the level please listen I
actually thought this one would be no
sweat off my back at all at all but the
accents terrible when usually I can do
it just fine and I have more trouble
concentrating that was a lot harder than
I would have thought he looks at you
when you panic Oh baby he's very cute
vinegar oh geez okay
well I was hoping I would never get that
one
it doesn't debilitate me in any way it's
just a huge bummer okay I have to go for
my shot of vinegar I bought in vinegar
specifically for this you're damn right
I party okay
also for the record it's not apple cider
vinegar it's just
it's just vinegar okay no it's fine
mm-hmm oh I don't know why I left it in
my mouth for so long
doesn't it doesn't go away you know no
no not a great time but okay here we go
we good okay okay okay another well
spent I don't know what it's gonna be
swap joique on okay I guess these things
all have puzzles but it's still gonna
help me get all the pieces so okay this
is this one on this hand this one in
this hand okay oh oh I already okay know
which one's gonna be walk this one this
one this one okay this is pretty odd
okay yep oh it's this is gonna look very
weird when you guys watch this game play
it's no wait wait wait no it's just
gonna be a lot of me standing and having
trouble moving oh oh oh boy Oh made so
big it seems so simple so difficult okay
and then we're gonna get you up here no
nope come on okay yep good and then you
need literally the opposite what I was
trying to do okay so much trouble like
aiming what I'm doing it this way okay
beautiful
that one's like on something isn't one
of these puzzles it's gonna be a bad
time for me I know it is okay I think
we've opened it oh I need some feedback
screw that okay let's go
oh is this actually the fight okay I
feel like I probably need to spin again
for this then huh
while flailing cool okay so I just have
to move the whole time oh oh this is oh
ok also hotter than I thought it would
be okay
okay cuz it's hard to like move the
camera and flail like an idiot I got all
the coins okay okay what's this oh oh no
oh my god
Oh harder thought I would have thought I
don't know where to go I don't know
where to go I don't want to go nope okay
no yeah it's constant constant moving
God keep moving along okay
these don't stop eventually right damn
it that's my first death because I was
flailing cheese okay thank you my power
level is impressive do you know what
it's over like four I think I've like
full arms how was it our first one yeah
why does he keep calling me tiny feel
like maybe a couple inches taller than
me that's rude huh he jump inside book
okay I just keep hoping that I don't
have to do another shot of vinegar why
do I do this to myself also very cute
this is ridiculous
all right Peggy peril it is wheel spin
it is let's go let's go let's do it
we got to hang out one hand again okay
please don't be too harsh on me this is
a proper level and not one of those
puzzle rooms so it's gonna be tougher
this time around
alright form good to go okay oh oh this
is gonna be really tough
if this jumping oh my god okay oh okay
no I'll figure it out there's got to be
a way to do it okay if I just oh oh we
made it can't believe we made it good so
what I did was just if I just push them
really close together it can actually
tap a while holding this obviously the
skull is gonna be terrible but you know
oh no I didn't jumping is hard okay what
is this okay nope I press it press the
stop button oh okay okay we're good
we're good we're good
okay yeah I'll take that and then no oh
jumping oh it's tough okay can I get
under this no wait there what can i
attack it climb no can't climb it so I
probably need to jump back and then jump
again right oh oh there's that oh oh
he's mean oh damn it okay well I could
just go whatever down to whatever I just
ran into it I just I just ran right into
it there we go
that's what we wanted jump be
Oh at the checkpoint does this can be
longer than there's a checkpoint in the
middle of it oh okay okay oh I really
thought I missed that I had fully given
up [ __ ] this okay not looking great
this is very difficult because it's hard
to when you're hitting another
controller to like I'm controlling it
with with that part of my thumb right so
it's like it's not easy it's what I'm
trying to say
Ok Go Go Go Go Luckey go get out of
there we don't have time we can't get
the coins I know you want them I want
them to with where one of the same okay
oh my god what happened there no we just
slipped watch out for him Oh checkpoint
jump just keep going lucky
oh you well you almost got the K nope
that's gonna hit you up alright good
not as good as planned at all nope oh
you're kidding I just didn't see it one
I might be out of lives
nope okay not again no it did get you
again it really did get you again okay
jump on that jump on that is this it
get me out of here
that was the hardest one yet I'm not
it's not done it's not done this is just
a different part of the map is okay
we're doing it this way is even harder
oh oh I don't know that I can our old
cousin I have to like move backwards
while pressing hey this is okay maybe
there's a way I can I wrap my foot I
don't want to Fahmy we wrap my fingers
around it and kind of okay down and then
here's one we're trying to hold it like
this
whomp oh that was tough
that's not not an easy time I don't know
I can't I can't I can't go that way
it's too hard a little lucky it's the
controller it's very difficult okay oh I
don't know why I got so scared
probably rightly so actually probably
right to me scared yep that's it very
difficult one hand is what got me to
fail new super Lucky's tale this
honestly was really fun though it's a
really difficult challenge that I
definitely want to try it with more
games a huge thank you to playful
studios for sponsoring this video if you
guys want to check it out maybe like
don't you use the wheel like I did you
don't have to do that part there is a
link in the description below it's way
you can check the game out but yeah I
hope you guys enjoy this video happy
holidays everyone and I will see you
guys next time bye